вина на сході україни у джима дітей до 5
років cave de apa слухати рожна ви
документального фільму школа номер три
адже буваєте доречним акула явка на
Донбасі равлик 2014 року буде для
школи та офісу місцю пост народжувала вигляд
боїв за слов'янську школу виду duvall і де
ти повернулася і в класи з приводу
зал і шилась а зйомкою фільму тревал і
блиск уроку у центрі про поведінку часток 13
школі промови парижі лавину
фільми знято замотав ми спектаклю моя ма
Кулаїв до українського драматурга Наталії
ворожить
то німецького режисера гордо дружина дружина
давно тикова українська тема you win ce
пивз основних the true переселенцем
києві діллона тема постановок частка людей
штифти кліві двини на сході України
війна в Україні вина в Україні ми не
здається на різниці розуміють лише і люди
в Україні
щіток та вина кремлівська пропаганда
кремлівська пропаганда мабуть і не
менше не дуже доброї проти
я просто стикаюсь стем що мулявіна у
вас там відриваючи перших на жаль по 1
набряк і трохи інакше з внутрішньою
українська громадян скоріше на ціни
правда я я сир і пара буваю на сході
україни розгуляюсь багатьма людьми і
кіза сепаратисти
за росію 95 адже сотки раптово трохи
рахунок російських військ там зростання і
військово для української апаратури фільмa
c шанс раз поvestea про путіна
Батьківщині це дуже класно що найза
розкол і така ситуація в Україні ми
можемо показати обійме одружитися кіно та
люди може за бачатою акціям на світ
збувається особливо його шове зшивають діти
гаситься товариства населення до і бишь
танків порада шува класно що люди
зможе допомогти це c і можна його поспит
чува ти просто вигляд блазня ситуацію в краї
не через вистачить і пшемисля допоміг ти там
вчитися навіть важливі ваші страви у світлі
джул і про те що ви буваєте в Україні
джетом бейну і це дуже погано
на прем'єрний показ фільму до Берліна
склеювати 15 лютого проїхав і головною
дорозі 11 школяр за школою номер три
розуму кулаєв ганьбу чекаю німецької столиці у
автобусі тревал а манжет 31 травня живий
сіуни
у берліні вперше я думаю що важливо поки що
я думаю ще шанував його показати їх фільм
в принципі всім людям і малюка в ньому ще
не
червоний здатися людям зіркових місця
різьблених краєм зіркових частим кольором шукаю
блюдо відразу мило і ще жити а на так і
просто розуміли що життя не таке
проста
тому що дасть на вигляд не знає dc
загорись знаходиться і що таке може бу
в офісі всі так думають про може писати
трохи вище, що судове я хочу, щоб знала
іноді щоб можна його розуміти нас
знали щоб навіть можливо знайшов
розуміли ска ближче знову для цик школі
риф прем'єра фільму про них ви найкраща на
дороги я так же, як ви важливі ви нагороду вони та
західному святу про те, що ж буваєте
на сході України як ваня говорила ось
просто у першому